we never thought we'd see the day when
the sweet and innocent Rapunzel would
swing her frying pan vanilla peas away
but the day has come
watching to the end to find out if
little vanellope has what it takes to
glitch herself out of harm's way
hmm so that's my friend Paige vanellope
strength princess vanellope might only
be eight years old but she's an
explosive character who never gives up
until she gets what's coming to her oh
what's that sorry we meant president
vanellope von schweetz has a nice ring
to it don't you think how could we
forget that the sugar rush presidents
didn't like to be referred to as a
princess that's our bad anywho Penelope
isn't someone who lets others walk all
over her which is why we're confident
that she would stand her ground for puns
okay him to sugar rash looking for a
fight at first glance Penelope looks
like a small child who can't defend
herself but appearances can be deceiving
because this kids as wild as they come
Penelope's strengths might be a little
odd but don't let them fool you after
all she's experienced when it comes to
taking out her enemies
the adorable president is an excellent
racer who has a little glitch up her
sleeve but funny enough she hates being
referred to as glitch and prefers to
call her condition kicks Lexia for most
of her life being a glitch stopped her
from going after her dreams but the
young ruler soon realized that her curse
could also be her biggest asset when it
comes to battling a nifty foe like
Rapunzel Penelope might just have the
upper hand however we'll have to see if
vanellope has mastered her guillotine
abilities before calling it in
Rapunzel's strength
Rapunzel might be 18 years old but she
isn't exactly mature after all she did
spend the majority of her life locked up
in a tower so by default her personality
is a little childish which makes her the
perfect match for vanellope nevertheless
the princess is super intelligent and
knows how to turn random objects into
weapons
knowing this we'd advise you to stay far
away from her if you ever see her
holding kitchen supplies in her hands
Rapunzel is extremely clever which makes
her a hard person to beat on top of that
she's got a string of special powers
that might just surprise you by now we
all know that Rapunzel's hair is magical
so it goes without saying that the
princess can't be harmed
should she be though she can easily heal
herself with her regeneration abilities
on top of that Rapunzel's hair seems to
have a mind of its own she uses her long
hair as though it were a rope and
manages to escape some pretty wild
scenarios this could make escaping
vanilla peas rat a little too easy don't
you think
Penelope's weaknesses when it comes down
to it vanilla pea is just a kid
so her list of weaknesses can go on and
on for starters she's not a gifted
fighter which can make capturing her an
easy thing to do on top of that she
tends to think with her emotions instead
of her brains which can complicate
things from time to time
Penelope might be a sweet and caring
ruler but she's not someone who forgives
people easily so anyone who's wronged
her in the past should steer clear from
roads of any kind because vanellope
might just bulldoze them if she gets the
chance if there's one thing vanellope
hates it's being bullied by others which
is only normal right
for as long as she can remember she was
the butt of every joke so it's safe to
say that her scars run deep
she also dislikes it when people tell
her what to do or worse prevent her from
doing what she wants to do all in all
this little hothead will put up a fight
for next to nothing
which is something to keep in mind all
Rapunzel has to know is that Penelope's
not particularly strong and she can't
heal herself if she gets hurt so in
other words things aren't looking too
good for our favorite sugar rush
character so what do you want with my
hair to cut it Rapunzel's weaknesses
Rapunzel is a bubbly princess who loves
wearing pink and purple which could
explain why vanellope would have a bone
to pick with her in the first place
she's brave selfless and friendly making
her the ideal princess
oddly enough Rapunzel doesn't seem to
have any weaknesses to her name instead
she's got a string of powers that most
people could only dream of the princess
of corona isn't unbeatable though
because let's face it few people are due
to her past it's only normal for
Rapunzel to have a problem with
captivity after all she spent 18 years
in a tower convinced that the world was
out to get her so if the young princess
has a weakness it would definitely be
her fear of confinement so what does for
puns will have that vanilla pea doesn't
a husband that's wet and last time we
being in love is a both a strength and a
weakness so in other words
Penelope could easily get the upper hand
if she were able to kidnap Eugene on top
of that Rapunzel's hair seems to be her
one true source of power so if her long
locks were cut short she lose her
ability to climb and swing about but as
shown in the movie tangled Rapunzel's
tears would still hold her healing
powers
Penelope's previous opponents vanellope
were to get into a fight with Rapunzel
tomorrow
she wouldn't exactly be unprepared after
all she did go head-to-head with King
candy in wreck-it Ralph were introduced
to an arrogant ruler who's managed to
pull the fast one over everyone's eyes
and even gets his disciples to call him
York and eNOS but funny enough this
arcade character is nothing more than a
sham the devious gamer will stop at
nothing to be a beloved ruler even if
that means erasing everyone's memories
King candy is a wicked foe and guess
what Penelope beat him with a little
help from her friends
despite being convinced that she was
nothing more than a glitch
Penelope followed her dreams all the way
to the finish line King candy or turbo
as we like to call him is a virus who
has an assortment of powers he's got
super strength and speed making him a
tough player to beat on top of that he's
an excellent racer who can hack into any
database despite being stronger and
brighter than vanilla pee in every
single way she was still able to beat
him and take back her throne so this
proves just how strong the little
presidents can be Rapunzel's previous
opponent when it comes to being lied to
and deceived we can all agree that
Rapunzel takes the cake the missing
princess spent her life believing that
her captor was indeed her mother which
is pretty messed up if you ask us the
person she loved more than anything
ended up being a manipulative witch who
used her magical hair to stay young and
beautiful whether Gothel is a wicked
disney villain who could stop just about
anyone
she's as ruthless as she is selfish
making her an enemy like no other
Gotha was a master manipulator who
wields the dagger without mercy despite
not having any abilities of her own
mother Gothel used Rapunzel's powers to
stay young and strong
so when Eugene came to rescue the love
of his life the Wicked Witch didn't
hesitate to use her dagger as a weapon
although it's true that Rapunzel
couldn't have defeated the old witch
without Eugene's help the same can
said about Penelope and Ralph on all
Rapunzel's giving personality has
allowed her to escape a gruesome fate on
more than one account
she's risked her own life for the people
she loves and minish defeats every foe
that came her way so the real question
is can the person who defeated Mother
Gothel also defeat King Candy's Viktor
we'll have to wait and see Penelope's
backup every princess needs a big strong
man to help her out of a jam or so were
taught to believe while it's true that
wreck-it Ralph unexpectedly came to
vanilla peas rescue she probably would
have discovered the truth on her own
well at least we hope she would have
Ralph might be considered as a villain
but he doesn't have a bad bone in his
body
however he's a master when it comes to
destroying things so all in all he's a
great person to have on your side
Ralph knows how it feels to be the
outcast which is what caused him to
leave his arcade game in the first place
he wanted to reinvent himself and did he
ever
Ralph possesses superhuman strength
which is something to fear and since
allies tend to help their friends during
battle we could only expect Ralph to
back up Penelope during her fights with
her puzzle
so while vanellope isn't the strongest
princess out of the bunch she's got a
big strong man fighting her battles
Ralph giant fists would definitely
frighten Eugene and Rapunzel but would
it be enough to get them to wave a white
flag
we highly doubt it Rapunzel's back up
when it comes down to it Rapunzel's got
a lot more backup than vanilla pea does
but what's that saying again quality is
better than quantity
so while Rapunzel's backup might be
stacked few people are a match for
Ralph's fists first in the list is the
master thief Flynn Rider or Eugene as we
like to call him he's Rapunzel's husband
and he's conniving smart agile and
strong so in other words he can put up a
fight like it's no big deal
second-in-command is Pascal he's great
at offering support and even better at
camouflage so while he might not be the
strongest member of the team he can
sneak into small places with ease and
last but not least is Maximus the most
determined force he'll ever meet
he's super strong and fast making him
comparable to a getaway car on top of
that Maximus knows how to fight with
weapons now that isn't impressive we
don't know what is why Rapunzel would
put up a good fight we want to get right
down to business and pick a winner but
before we can do that
to take a look at how the battle would
go although vanellope might be able to
race circles around her opponent Maximus
is far from being a slowpoke so we
wouldn't be surprised if her puzzle
could escape vanilla piece advances with
ease
on top of that rapunzel could easily
trap her opponent with her long locks of
hair and then imprison her in her
castles dungeons with eugene in Pascal's
health
the princess would sneak into vanilla
peas castle undetected but the same
can't be said about Ralph
after all he leaves a path of
destruction wherever he goes but when it
comes to escaping her captors Penelope
is a master after all her glitch allows
her to jump from place to place all in
all rapunzel is stronger than vanellope
and her magical properties prevent her
from getting hurt but when it comes to
winning the battle only one of the
princesses will take home the trophy
Rapunzel would put up a good fight but
in the end and she really beats a glitch
yeah this lady named shap she actually
made the video she's the one who told us
that comes to you and the winner is
shovel please
none other than president Penelope while
losing to a child is never easy there is
little that Rapunzel can do about it
after all there's no such thing as
beating a glitch
Penelope might be inferior in this
strength Department but she's got more
than enough muscle on her team
Rapunzel's weaknesses are her biggest
downfall so if broth captures you gene
so basically forfeit the match on top of
that if Rapunzel ever stepped foot in
sugar rash
she'd risk being in prison which is
basically her kryptonite Penelope on the
other hand could glitch herself out of
any scenario making her impossible to
beat in the end
Rapunzel would have a hard time laying a
single strand of hair on vanellope and
Brow's fists would never miss the mark
and besides you could harvest someone as
adorable as vanellope von schweetz
so there you have it guys the good twins
again before you go let us know if you
think there's another Disney Princess
who could give vanellope a run for her
money and that's a wrap thanks for
watching
don't forget to subscribe to the things
to be the first in line to watch our
newest videos we'll see you next time
[Music]